Exercise, exercise, exercise, that's all you
hear!
Get off the couch, Trace!
Come run a race with me, TRACE!!
Here's what I say, "Nope.
Science says it's gonna kill you."
Hey there avid runners and couch potatoes,
according to science, you're basically the
same!
I'm Trace, thanks for watching DNews.
In 1976, the number of marathon finishers
was 25,000; in 2013, it was 541,000 people.
We sure seem to be running more than ever!
With the number of races exploding -- there
were only 300 marathons nationwide in 2000
-- now there are over 1,100!
So, is all this running an indicator of our
nation's awesome health?
Not… really…
We're ALL told some exercise is better than
no exercise, and in general that is true,
but according to new research published in
the Journal of the American College of Cardiology,
too much of a good thing, can often be too
much to bear.
According to the study, people who run at
a "fast pace" more than four hours in a week,
spread over three sessions or more; had the
same risk of death as those who were sedentary
and hardly exercised at all.
Basically, sitting on your couch and doing
nothing is unhealthy.
Sedentary people risk heart disease, obesity
and other health problems, but running 240
minutes per week -- or almost 35 minutes per
day -- carries the SAME RISK.
Shocking, I know.
Yogging came on to the scene in the 70s, It's
not a soft J…
Okay, Jogging, then.
That sounds weird, but whatever.
But this avid running increased the mortality
rate.
According to this same study though, it's
easy to fix: JUST RUN LESS and SLOWER.
See, those who ran more than 2.5 hours in
a week, over three or more sessions; at a
fast pace had a mortality rate of 66%.
But those who ran 1 to 2.4 hours a week, in
LESS than three sessions; at a "slow to moderate
pace," had a significant reduction in that
mortality.
In fact, "light jogging" has been shown to
increase lifespan by 6.2 years for men and
5.6 for women.
Before you freak out, scientists controlled
for sex, age, medical history, and lifestyle
factors like smoking and alcohol consumption.
They followed almost 20,000 people for 40
years and used this massive dataset to learn
about a variety of diseases -- including connecting
JOGGING with health, and now "avid running"
with, well, not health.
According to their results, the graph is sort
of an inverted U shape, with inactive, and
overactive at the bottom.
I immediately think of the benefits of coffee
or wine -- one 8 ounce cup or glass is fine
-- but more than that and benefits decrease
precipitously and you head into unhealthy
behaviorland.
But as a runner, I wonder what a "slow to
moderate pace" is?
Right?
According to one of the researchers, the pace
of "slow joggers corresponds to vigorous exercise,"
while the faster pace is "very vigorous exercise."
A doctor from UCLA who wasn't part of the
research said we weren't meant to mountain
bike or marathon run every day -- and this
research shows, if we want to live longer,
we probably shouldn't.
Other research states long-term strenuous
exercise, like marathons and triathlons might
harm the heart.
But the risk is really low, heart attacks
among marathoners is lower or equal to athletes
in other sports -- but there's very little
to gain by simply exercising MORE and MORE.
This is in no way an attempt to dissuade people
from marathons or vigorous exercise.
The benefits are there, we've reported on
them, but everything in moderation, as they
say.
And definitely never just sit on the couch.
No way, José.
People who are physically active have a 30%
lower risk of death, as opposed to those who
aren't.
So get off your butt a few times a week and
walk, jog or whatever.
Just do something.